this is why the psychedelic experience
and psychedelics are so important it's
because they are tools for understanding
and revision in the reality in which we
all live the personal growth is a
wonderful thing and will naturally
follow along but it's more important
than that it's a way to make a new world
that is Taoist ik feminine free of
anxiety and in great anticipation of
further stages of completion lying into
the future that's that's where the
mystery the transcendental object the
clod of gold at the end of the rainbow
is waiting and I think that's the job of
each of us to show our best toys and our
best tricks that lift us and our friends
to higher and higher levels and there is
no end to this bootstrapping process
that the future of the human mind and
body and the future of humans together
is endlessly bright
keep the faith recognize each other and
maybe I should close with a little line
from Gary Snyder if I can remember it
he said learn the flowers travel light
stay together
you
you